Oh
young things generally tend to be
curious especially those that have
something that you can really get your
mind around say those creatures have
brains they have enough of a
concentration of nerve cells that that
they can have a reaction to things they
might even anticipate danger and react
accordingly do they dream do they
anticipate the future that reflect on
the past the way humans do well we're
still trying to figure that out I'm
convinced that other creatures many
other creatures have more going for them
in terms of intelligence and reasoning
capacity than we give them credit for
I'm confident that the dolphins and
whales have a level of intelligence in
some cases that we wish we had you think
about sperm whales they have the biggest
brain on the planet they have close-knit
societies they do things that we we
don't know why they do them we we see
them doing group behavior getting
together in us in a circle that some
have designated a Marguerite formation
because it's a bit like the glass that a
margarita is served in like a flower
with a with a narrow base to it they all
some signal get together and dive down
all at once to do what or why we're not
smart enough yet to figure it out we're
not sperm whales but that they do and
that they can hold their breath for an
hour and find food that they engage big
squid that they travel over thousands of
miles with no roadmap go back to the
same place time and time again they're
things that I wish we had inherent in
our capacity or to be a tuna fish for
heaven's sakes that travel over
thousands of miles and come back to the
same place to have chemoreceptors that
we have we can smell that's a kind of
chemo reception but to have a face that
has taste buds that extend around up
over the over your whole face the way
many fish do or to be able to senses
sharks do an electrical field all
creatures can have some
an electrical field around them we do
fish do lobsters do but to be able to
sense it to know that they're there
maybe we do have some primitive or
shadow effect that gives us some sense
of where we are in relation to other
things but sharks really have it that's
how they find food at night when you
can't see but they can sense where they
are the lateral line down many bony
fishes that enable them to sense we
think we don't know we don't have a
lateral line but we speculate that it
enables them to sense movement so you
get these tight formations of fish that
look as though they're moving as one
fish they are so close it's like the
blue angels but times a thousand because
they move like this like streams of
silver bait of ten thousand little
pieces that move as if they're just all
coordinated on on wires but they're not
they're independent if only we could
feel what they feel and see what they
see to have the eyes of some of the deep
sea fish that are exquisitely developed
to be able to see low light levels with
with receptors and things that glow like
like a cat's iron or a dog's eye that
sense the tiniest amount of light when
we get to a thousand feet in the sea
even in in high noon broadest light
daylight and and the clearest ocean
water at a thousand feet you can still
barely make out shapes and forms but
it's beyond that it's really dark to our
sensors but to a fish to these deep-sea
fish for them they can see a cat can see
at night only much more sensitive it's
because many of these are tuned to sense
bioluminescent light the Firefly kind of
light that characterizes most of the
ocean you get below a thousand feet it's
dark but there are these little lights
flash and sparkle and glow it's like
diving in
galaxy even our eyes pick up the late
but these creatures that have enhanced
light gathering capacity suck having
night-vision goggles silence of the lamb
fair there you are you can see nobody
else can see these fish has the capacity
to see
the capacity to see what we can't see so
they have gifts